welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar keynote
presentation cannabis for mental health
what consumers need to know
presented by jan roberts a licensed
clinical social worker and CEO and
director of translational research at
the international research center on
cannabis and mental health my name is
Susie Valdez and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring it as educational web seminar
presented by elaborate lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type those questions
into the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation please click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming Jan Roberts I will now turn
the presentation over to her welcome Jim
thank you thank you so much for having
me hello everyone my name is Jan Roberts
I'm a licensed clinical social worker I
also own and operate partners in health
and well-being a large mental health
practice along the mid-atlantic we see
about 16,000 patients a year I'm also
the CEO and director of translational
research for the International Research
Center on cannabis and mental health I
teach it in weiu focusing on mental
health and social work and I'm really
delighted to be here today I got into
cannabis and cannabis research really to
help my patients understand
more about what was happening and how
cannabis could be useful for them in
treating mental health conditions and
this is such an exciting field because
for us we know that there's a lot of
misinformation out there so today we're
going to talk about what consumers need
to know so that as a consumer you can
really have a better understanding about
how cannabis can affect you from a
mental health and wellness perspective
so today our learning objectives are
really to identify the current deficits
and knowledge and attitudes that mental
health providers have because and as an
educated consumer you want to know
exactly what's going on in the field and
what potential struggles clinicians
might be having related to cannabis and
understanding it all so we're going to
learn about how cannabis can positively
impact patients and impact you we're
gonna learn about concerns around
current cannabis research as well as
learning about the challenges that
current patients have with cannabis
treatment this is a huge issue for us at
IRC CMH because for us it is about the
patients and it is about making sure
that people have adequate objective
information to help them navigate this
landscape of using cannabis for help for
me it's important to see cannabis as a
gateway to wellness and and I've come
with this kind of thought around it just
because cannabis is a gateway to
wellness because it provides providing
that its use is focused on the
regulation of the endocannabinoid system
in mental health historically we've
always looked at cannabis as a potential
problematic use or problematic
maladaptive coping skill and there is
certainly a bias in the mental health
community about looking at cannabis from
a pathological lens but for our purposes
and from the emerging research is that
who we really focus on cannabis as it
relates to the endocannabinoid
system we can actually improve someone's
mental health so currently within mental
health treatment there are several
challenges that affect us and as a
clinician myself I have personally
experienced this you know I was trained
to look at cannabis use under the guise
of substance use disorder to look at it
as pathology our cannabis use disorder
and many of my colleagues we've all been
trained kind of under that and where
that comes from is essentially back in
the 70s with Nixon's administration and
the war on drugs
there was Lyda was created and NIDA was
created essentially that's the National
Institute of drug abuse was created to
to essentially focus on cannabis use
from a problematic lens in fact one of
its core components was really to
identify how cannabis would negatively
impact people so all of the research
that started to emerge we're really
focused on cannabis use as a
pathological use rather than a
health-related use or a preventive use
so the research has been focused on
maladaptive use we tend to focus on
substance not on the behavior that
actually might be exacerbating that we
also know that patients currently use
cannabis for the treatment of their
mental health symptoms in fact other
than pain cannabis is mostly used for
the treatment of anxiety and depression
and these are from national studies
where people report why that they use
cannabis and so it's important and I
would have to argue that cannabis use
really is more about therapeutic use
rather than I hate the term recreational
use or adult use because really if
people are using it to reduce their
stress levels if they're using it to
kind of unwind at the end of the night
one would argue that that actually is
kind of a therapeutic and revenge
there there's also a lack of education
around the endocannabinoid system as
well as healthy cannabis use and what
happens with mental health treatment is
that patients often don't talk about
their use they're afraid of being
stigmatized they're afraid of if they're
discuss it with their clinicians that
they're going to be labeled as a STONER
or a pothead or someone with cannabis
use disorder so often times in my
experience as a clinician is that
clients or patients didn't really feel
comfortable talking about that and
that's a huge issue when it comes to
mental health treatment and there's also
this large misperception about cannabis
cannabis is not one drug cannabis is a
compound and we'll get into that further
one so last spring I actually conducted
a survey dr. marcoh and I conducted a
survey on mental health clinician
clinicians looking at their knowledge
and attitudes around cannabis and it was
a pilot study it was a small study and
the findings from the study really kind
of were fascinating and actually we
found some statistically significant
data around this there wasn't a lack of
agreement among the clinicians who were
participants or the difference between
healthy use and what abuse was with
cannabis in addition most recommended
cannabis for treatment of physical
conditions rather than mental health
conditions and that kind of difference
also kind of reveals the lack of
knowledge about how cannabis can
actually positively impact mental health
outcomes in addition most of the
clinicians surveyed were uneducated
about the ECS that's the endocannabinoid
system and how the impact on mood how
the ECS can actually impact mood there
was also a lot of confusion around
cannabis effect on future drug use so
for example there was an agreement about
the Gateway theory some clinicians
reported that
wasn't really true whereas a few
actually said that you know what the
Gateway theory might be true but the
biggest concern was around the risk for
psychosis or schizophrenia and we even
see that today and the research where we
get kind of competing and different
kinds of data demonstrating whether or
not cannabis has any kind of correlation
with psychosis you know and that's a
whole other issue that I'm fascinated by
because the studies what we do know is
that oftentimes people who are in
prodromal stages of schizophrenia tend
to self-medicate a lot and that's
usually you know so the question is is
there a causation or is there just a
correlation between cannabis use and
psychosis most however in the study that
we did this pilot study knew really
little about dosing they knew little
about the biphasic effect which the
biphasic effect is essentially that with
cannabis as in with many other drugs you
have to find the right dosage to little
it's not therapeutic too much actually
causes problems so very few of
clinicians really understood that
healthy cannabis use is really about
finding what the right dosages also
little information was known about how
micro dosing of cannabis could impact
mood as well as the chemical composition
of cannabis and different cannabinoids
and terpenoids and how they may impact
mood as well as receptors and stuff like
that and there was also little
information about how people could be
affected by different methods of
consumption and it was really
fascinating to me that recommendations
for cannabis or clinicians who were more
likely to be supportive of cannabis use
with their patients were actually it was
found mostly with clinicians who've had
their own experience with cannabis use
clinicians who did not have any
experience with their own
their own personal lives with cannabis
use actually felt very they they
actually were more afraid to recommend
that so one of the things out of this
study is that we were awarded a grant
through my you to actually increase it
with dr. lawless Rosner where we're
going to be having expanding the study
internationally to look at other mental
health clinicians throughout the world
and seeing what knowledge they have
around cannabis and cannabis use and
this is important because if our
providers really don't have adequate
knowledge or have attitudes that are
based and stigmatization that came from
research that they're less likely to
create an environment where patients can
talk about this and they're less likely
to really understand the nuances of
mental health treatment that cannabis
can provide for their clients so I'm
gonna kind of shift a little bit and
talk about the EECS the easiest is the
endocannabinoid system and how does that
exactly relate to mental health well we
know that the goal of the ECS is to
maintain homeostasis and that even
includes emotional Komeito stasis
homeostasis probably I always have a
hard time explaining what that means
that essentially homeostasis is a state
of healthy functioning and so the ECS is
job is to help maintain healthy
functioning within the body
we all have an endocannabinoid system
and it's fascinating because this ECS
actually impacts emotional well-being
and we'll get into that in a second
so the goal of the ECS is to help you
know is responsible for a sleep relaxing
and forgetting and these are things that
humans and other animals need to be able
to kind of function in a healthy way so
for example if someone's not sleeping
there's no way that they're going to be
healthy and actually I've had patients
who because of lack of sleep actually
became psychotic so it's important that
our bodies have this ability to eat
sleep relax and forget
the easiest uses cannabinoid receptors
that are located in the central nervous
system the peripheral nervous system and
immune systems it identified
dysfunctions it kind of remediates and
it restores to healthy functioning so
it's very important for all of us to
have a healthy endocannabinoid system
but what does that have to do with mood
regulation so we know again that the EC
s is really responsible for helping
wellness by maintaining healthy
functioning themselves by maintaining
healthy functioning of neurons etc so in
the central nervous system we know that
the receptor C v1 is mostly found in the
brain even though it exists outside of
EC and s the central nervous system
we know that the cb2 receptors primarily
found outside the CMS the central
nervous system and its associated with
the immune function but it seems that
the cv one it's the most abundant
receptor in the brain so this is a
cannabinoid receptor and the really
important piece about this is that this
receptor it's not found in the brainstem
and that's the area that controls
respiration and we'll kind of get as we
talk about opioids in a bit we can kind
of talk about that the importance of
that it's also one of the reasons why
well I'll go ahead and say now why you
know if someone utilizes cannabis their
respiration is not going to be affected
however if someone is using an opioid
and uses too much of that opioid because
of the receptors it actually can shut
down respiration and that's usually what
we see with a lot of their vertices from
opioids so how does ECS and cannabis
potentially impact on mood regulation so
we we've noticed that the EC s has been
identified as a regulator brain activity
hormonal function and immune response it
links these three major regulatory
systems together
if it's functioning in a healthy way it
actually leads to healthy mood
regulation the ECAs and I love this
quote from Hillard it modulates
virtually every brain rate region and
thereby contributes to nearly every
function of the central nervous system
and we know that with the EC s that if
it is responsible for healthy
functioning then what happens if there
isn't healthy functioning what happens
if there's disease or illnesses Ethan
Rousseau in 2004 he coined the term
clinical endocannabinoid deficiency
syndrome and the hypothesis is that you
know the well-regulated ECS leads to
help but the dysregulated
endocannabinoid system actually leads to
illness such as inflammation and healthy
neuronal functioning in the brain and
that emotional homeostasis is vital for
mental health and healthy mental health
functioning everything affects brain
chemistry everything does the music you
listen to the foods you eat the friends
you keep everything can affect your
brain chemistry so the thought is is if
we want to have a healthy brain
chemistry we really need to have a
healthy ECS so this is viewed by some as
the bridge between the body and the mind
connecting the physical reality with an
emotional and an intellectual one it's
hypothesized that exogenous cannabinoids
like cannabis which is a phyto
cannabinoid that means it's a
cannabinoid found within the plant that
you can actually use those to supplement
the easiest to bring about healthy
ECS regulation so this is where cannabis
really fits into the mental health piece
is that cannabis can be viewed as a way
to regulate the endocannabinoid system
so if we know that the EECS modulates
the activity of a variety of neural
pathways including those pathways that
affect avoidance and withdrawal such as
fear and the stress response that we
really need to be looking at these yes
it helps tune the emotional and stress
stress responses in humans and in
animals so if stress impacts the ECS a
dysregulated ecs will actually impact
how we experience a stress so cannabis
is impacting mood regulation can be
vital here we know like I said earlier
that patients report that they use
cannabis for depression they use it for
anxiety
we know that THC is a cannabinoid
actually has antidepressant effects CBD
although it makes you an alert it also
has NZ oolitic effects and that's that's
I guess a fancy way of saying it reduces
anxiety we are however unsure about the
role of other cannabinoids and
terpenoids and right now that for me is
a really fascinating field to root to
have better understanding about how CG
or cbn can actually impact that as well
and then what are the entourage effects
of these molecular compounds actually
working together related to nud we know
inand amide the endogenous cannabinoids
in tanti depressant effects cb1
receptors in the prefrontal cortex and
the visceral hyper campus hippocampus
that is they're responsible for creating
anxiety quite an antidepressant like
except effects so the activation of cb1
receptors in the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex actually even leads to reduce
startle reflex and that's important for
someone with PTSD and what does that
mean that means that we have these
potential applications for cannabis may
based medicines and this is a vital very
important
and kind of thing because if we look at
how the ECS works if we look at how
these different cannabinoids can impact
the brain theoretically then we have an
opportunity to use cannabis to help
regulate one's mood right now most of
the research in mental health and
cannabis has been based on animal based
models you know when they made the
introduction they said I'm the director
of translational medicine here at IRC
CMH and essentially my job is to help
create patient focused research help
create research that we're actually
looking at how patients or participants
humans essentially are being impacted so
we know that there's very little
experimental research on humans
involving randomized control trials and
there are lots of reasons behind that
and that most of the research like I
mentioned earlier has been focused on
pathology but it's also focused on
cannabis it really doesn't individually
look at what the individual chemo VARs
are and their impact on people so again
remember I said that cannabis is not one
drug it's a compound that consists of
many different chemo VARs that have
potential impacts for mood regulation
so most of research out there you know
when I read a project and/or research
article and I'm reading about what
they're talking about cannabis I'm
always asking well what was the chemical
makeup of this you know what was the THC
level what was the CVD level what was
the CBN level borther terpenoids
and most of the studies out there really
aren't looking at that and that's really
here just like me saying that I am going
to study and to depress its own people
well we know that there are different
types of antidepressants that have
different methods of action so
can't really describe you know the
effect of zoloft like I would wellbutrin
because they're totally different types
of antidepressants so using that kind of
analogy we can't really say that when
researchers are looking at cannabis if
we do don't have a clear picture of the
chemical compounds of that cannabis we
really can't extrapolate what the impact
is on clients or on the participants
another huge issue and we we've come up
with this at IRC CMH alive is that
oftentimes there's a lack of supply to
do really good research I'll give you a
great example in the state of Delaware
we were wanting to look at clinical
efficacy of certain varieties on PTSD
and veterans unfortunately we couldn't
guarantee that we could have enough
supply of this same variety so that we
could compare the exact same batch the
exact same chemical profile of the
cannabis that we were studying
throughout the entire length of the
study so lack of supply actually really
does hinder our ability to perform great
research ornamental health in addition
their lack of standardized products
because of prohibition we can't ship
products across state lines so something
that is grown in Massachusetts might
even though theoretically it should have
the same chemical makeup if it's grown
in say Colorado it might be a little bit
different just because of how it's grown
and other kind of issues so prohibition
actually negatively impacts our current
research on mental health as well and
it's so difficult because of these
nuances that people often don't
understand that prohibition and every
state's regulations really kind of keep
us from performing high quality research
or more research for that matter but
what does that mean to the consumer well
this is where I
he's really get concerned because I have
had it where I've had consumers or
patients of mine come in they've heard
something great in the news about a
product or CVD for example and they come
in in fact I had this happen once where
a patient came in and she's like look I
found this I bought it at the store what
do you think and we couldn't really look
at the testing there wasn't any
information around the testing and what
the testing had had demonstrated and so
from my perspective it was an unsafe
product because I couldn't guarantee its
safety and what this is just one of the
many issues that patients face
oftentimes there's lack of education
about products even if a patient goes
into a medical dispensary they're having
someone with no healthcare background
giving them information about products
oftentimes it can be intimidating to
patients oftentimes what the budtender
and I hate that word but I'm going to
use in there or patient advocate as
they're called what they provide is just
kind of a very rudimentary like yeah I
hear this is good for that condition I
hear this is good for that you know and
so they really don't have a clear
understanding about potential drug drug
interactions stuff like that so we have
people who aren't educated on mental
health medical issues providing patients
with guidance around what cannabis
products to use and that's a huge issue
and it can be very confusing the names
and the varieties and what do they mean
and what does it really work etc another
issue that patients face or supply
related issues and that's a huge issue
I've had it where I've had clients who
were using certain products that found
them to be very helpful only to when
they go back the next week to get the
same product it's not available and they
can't find out
and it will be available and these are
really incredibly important issues that
patients are facing we would never say
okay you're taking your beta blocker
this prescription hopefully the
pharmacist will have it next week for
you but in cannabis were seeing this all
the time where supply related issues are
actually impacting patient care another
thing is that patients aren't really
educated around what the biphasic
effectives and even though we always
here start slow you know started a
little bit and start it slow and let's
see how it works
patients often don't understand that
there's a reason that we're doing that
we want to find the optimal dose for
that patient and the reality is is that
everyone even metabolizes cannabis in a
different way also patients have very
little information about the end of
cannabinoid system and what a
dysregulated into cannabinoid system
even is and how that could impact them
and then finally it's that lack of safe
standardized products that I see as a
clinician and here at this Institute
that we are constantly concerned with we
had I know it IRC CMH we've produced
consumer warnings related to CBD
products and encouraging people to
actually use standardized safe products
and knowing their their sources because
if there is not a standardized safe
product out there and usually we find
these in dispensaries that that could
actually lead to negative outcome so we
have this consumer warning based on a
Virginia Commonwealth study that came
out recently a few months ago and
essentially we told people please don't
use it unless you know where it's coming
from and that there have been certain
standards put into place and that
they've been manufactured with safe
practices
and one of the things we the reason we
did that was because the actual research
on these products showed that there were
actually counterfeit CBD products out
there it had not real
CBD it was a manufactured CBD and
oftentimes these oils would have
additional components in them that it
could actually exacerbate mental health
conditions in fact some of the chemicals
that were found and the samples actually
were found in k2 and in spice and would
exacerbate anxiety and so people who are
taking CBD for anxiety
all of a sudden might have an adverse
reaction because of these other
chemicals and they don't realize it's
really about the lack of standardized
and safe products than it is about CBD
and people think that if I can buy it it
means it must be safe that's not always
the case unfortunately it's not always
the case we get you know we get
contacted constantly about this you know
whether it's through attorneys that are
are involved in lawsuits related to
unsafe products or we've had it you know
through our own research and we have a
project that we're about to launch as
well looking at these kinds of products
as well so I talked to you a little bit
about a patient advocate and the bud
tenders kind of making these medical
decisions and that's a huge issue one of
the grow largest growing populations of
cannabis users now are people older than
50 and you know I love to go and sit in
dispensaries and see I love to people
watch you know I guess I'm a therapist
so of course I love to people watch but
it's fascinating to see how people
become very confused about what they
should be using what they shouldn't be
using so we're lacking a lot of
Education with patient advocates and
again any state and I don't care what
state it is that allows medical does
to be made by patient advocates instead
of pharmacists or physicians you know
it's it's highly alarming another issue
that patients face related to medical
cannabis is access to care there's a
reality here that it's a very costly
thing to get a medical cannabis card
oftentimes physicians won't sign off on
it or they've been instructed by the
healthcare organization they write they
work for not to sign off on medical
cannabis applications
unfortunately I run into that alive
where like probably some of the best
health care systems in the country are
actively telling their physicians that
they're not allowed to sign off on
medical cannabis applications for
patients regardless of the condition
because of the concern of liability in
losing federal funding it's a huge issue
and what happens is then patients have
to go to another physician that they
might not even know who they are but
that physician is going to be reviewing
records and making that recommendation
and helping them get their medical card
while I believe that this is a very
important thing to have it's very costly
incredibly costly venture for patients
they can't build with their insurance
they can't use their insurance to go
through those companies they have to pay
out-of-pocket oftentimes it's hundreds
and hundreds of dollars just to be able
to get a physician to sign off on a
medical card and think about what that
means that means that a subset of our
population can't afford to get into
these programs and say even if they do
get into these programs insurance
doesn't pay for cannabis and oftentimes
because of the trial and error issue
because we're not really looking at how
people metabolize different cannabinoids
people are having to try this variety
and that might not work so then they're
going to have to try
other variety it's not in common for
patients that I've seen for example for
them to have to spend hundreds of
dollars just to be able to find a
variety that works for them and because
of that that's again we are limiting
access to a medication because of these
issues so that you only have people who
can afford this I think that's one of
the reasons we continually see the
black-market going because it's almost
easier just to stick with the black
market than it is to jump through all of
these hoops that are actually
prohibiting people to to get access to
the care that they need and of course
with the black market you don't have you
don't know what varieties you're using
you don't know if pesticides have been
used we don't know you know if mold or
any yeast or anything like that or in
the supply and so it goes back to the
safe standardized products are not
available to people in addition we
hadn't really talked a lot about drug
drug interactions depending on the
method of consumption it really could
impact how cannabis and other drugs are
metabolized and this is something that
as a Research Institute were really
fascinated with because we we understand
that you have to be able to look the
water drug drug interactions and
patients don't really think about that
I'll give you you know I'll talk about
some cases and in the future in a few
moments but I'll give you a great
example one of my clients
she was recommended to use by a
budtender a certain variety that made
her incredibly anxious while she was
taking her klonopin along with it and
she didn't understand that no you're not
supposed to feel that way and so we
really have to pay attention to what
these drug drug interactions are and we
have to do a much better job about
educating patients one of the things I'm
seeing in the
that I'm actually kind of excited about
is that now we have patients who are
driving a lot of these changes not so
much the physicians because the
physicians don't really understand a lot
about cannabis but it's the patients who
are becoming much more educated around
this so what are some of the issues that
providers face we know that 9 percent of
medical schools in the u.s. teach about
the endocannabinoid system only 9
percent of medical schools that's
amazing to me
so that means basically 81 percent of
medical schools or medical students who
are being who are graduating to become
physicians don't have real understanding
about the endocannabinoid system and
that's not even including psychologists
clinical social workers counselors
nurses it's not even including other
healthcare professionals or pharmacists
who really are seeing patients and
interacting with patients on a daily
basis most providers don't even
understand that cannabis really is a
compound unless they've gone through
some special training they don't people
tend to kind of again think of cannabis
as one drug well not all cannabis is the
same it's like the analogy I made with
the antidepressants and to depressants
are different because of their chemical
makeup so is cannabis and often times as
providers we tend to attribute that
people are wanting to use cannabis to
get high
that there's a motivation for cannabis
just to be stoned rather than really
seeing the therapeutic importance of
that cannabis can play and we really you
know this is such a nuanced field and I
always get nervous when I read research
articles and they're in these grand
statement
about you know cannabis causes psychosis
or whatever you know that a lot of you
know it's very nuanced so what does the
science say about cannabis but also what
does it not say you know we know for
example with psychosis that there are
some kind of correlation what that is we
don't know exactly what that is but we
do not see causation so it's important
for providers to really have the latest
science I can tell you I teach about
cannabis to mental health practitioners
and physicians and I always encourage
people that once you know or to students
who are who are who are graduating to be
these and I always encourage people to
stay on top the research is so
cutting-edge right now that you need to
continually read about cannabis to stay
on top of what the science is saying and
also as providers we need to be able to
pay attention to what are the strengths
of someone who uses cannabis and how can
cannabis be used to enhance someone's
life for me if I have a patient who is
using cannabis and they're not engaging
in their life they're not feeling
activated to join and enjoy their life
then it's really not a healthy thing for
them the last thing I want to do is to
see someone who is going to escape their
life with cannabis use because cannabis
can actually help activate and help
people lead the best lives they can use
they can lead and if it's doing the
opposite then it's it's not enhancing
their life and we want to stay away from
that so one of the things I also really
like to teach with my patients is what
is a dysregulated ECS and how can I pay
attention so if I'm using cannabis I
need to really pay attention to certain
things to make sure that I'm not using
too much because according to the
biphasic effect you know I can even dis
regulate my endocannabinoid system if
I'm using too much of cannabis so if
someone these are some potential signs
of a dysregulated ECS if you're highly
sensitive to pain if you have increased
some
items of anxiety or depression if
there's chronic inflammation and some
Nia to the point of taking medication
having to take medication to go to sleep
bone loss having chronic pain
dementia-like symptoms a family history
of cancer or even the lack of motivation
these are potential signs of a
dysregulated into cannabinoid system so
that could be that maybe you need to
supplement with cannabis to help
regulate it or not use so much if you're
using too much cannabis these are some
of the mental health issues impacted by
cannabis stress depression anxiety PTSD
autism anorexia schizophrenia sleep
sexual related issues and substance use
disorders most people like I said use
cannabis for depression and anxiety and
pain relief but when you hear people who
are and I come across the gamut of a
whole variety of types of patients who
use cannabis that they feel that
cannabis is a great stress reducer it
helps them unwind it helps them kind of
relax after a long day at the office you
know for a PTSD I focus a lot on PTSD
with my clients and and I'll get into
that in a moment when I talk about this
specific case that there the research is
showing that there are definitely some
especially from the animal model
research some potential potentialities
for cannabis for the treatment of PTSD
we know that it's also been helpful in
sleep issues we know for sexual related
issues at about two-thirds of people who
who use cannabis actually report having
enhanced sexuality and sexual
experiences in fact I'm in the podcast
with my colleague Jay Han Marco and
Greer Barnes and Randy Cameron who are
actors and comedians and we actually on
our podcast it's called
times we actually discussed this the
other day there was a recent research
article that showed that cannabis and
this was with I think University and st.
Louis where they had looked at females
and their sexuality and found that
cannabis was actually positively linked
to female orgasms that it actually
impacted positively impacted women who
were having orgasms that allowed them to
have more orgasms more and so there was
a lot of really exciting stuff coming up
related to cannabis and how it can
positively impact mental health issues
we also know especially and I know I'm
talking about sexual related disorders
here but one of the reasons people get
off of antidepressants is because of
sexual side effects so here we have this
compound this cannabis compound that
actually can enhance sexuality and maybe
even provide relief from depressive
symptoms so these are some of the things
that there are some potentialities here
for cannabis based medicines I will say
this I think there is a tendency in this
field to always think about cannabis as
the perfect answer for everything and it
is not that we really need to be smart
about cannabis use just like anything
you know anything can become a disorder
it can be eating too much food it can be
shopping too much it can be
relationships it can be a lot of
different behaviors that present present
potential problems for us the cannabis
does have an abuse potential as do many
other substances and behaviors and to me
this is a very powerful thing for us to
acknowledge because you know this is
empowerment this is about teaching
consumers that they're responsible for
their bodies and they might want to make
sure that they're living as helpfully as
possible so cannabis as in many other
things does have an abuse potential my
rule of thumb is if you're using
anything
to escape your your reality day in and
day out then that might be problematic
whether that's food relationships
whatever but we do know that there is an
abuse potential there and I work with my
clients to make sure that they're using
it in a therapeutic way and I find that
most people want to use it in a
therapeutic way and I have to say there
is nothing wrong with you for iya there
is nothing wrong with getting high as
long as you're still living that vital
life that you should be living you know
the Gateway theory is something
especially in my field that I was I was
trained in and the Gateway theory has
been debunked you know people tended to
focus on cannabis as the gateway to
other drugs but they really weren't
paying attention to coping and
psychological issues that might have
been actually exacerbating potential
drug use and that's vital we have to
look at how poor coping can create
potential dependency issues anywhere so
like for example any you know we see
this for populations of obese people
who've had gastric bypass surgery they
are at a higher rate of alcoholism as a
result and the reason is is because
you've removed their food source they
can't eat to the extent that they used
to but they can drink so it's really
about how do people cope with life
rather than the substance per se and we
want to make sure that people have
healthier coping skills you know there
is nothing wrong with going home and
unwinding with a glass of wine going
home and unwinding you know with a joint
but are you living that vital life and
that's what we're shooting for for me I
combine mindfulness based awareness and
my practices with my patients you know I
think that's important too to ensure
that my patients are paying attention to
how cannabis affects them just from the
ECS perspective but also is this adding
to their life or creating the harm
because we want to be able to add value
and I use mindfulness based awareness to
really help people look at how they cope
with life you know but here's the cool
part withdrawal from cannabis actually
kind of mimics caffeine you know we see
some anxiety nervousness restlessness
irritability and sleep difficulties and
it really doesn't last that long it
usually begins a couple of days
afterwards at peaks in a week it can go
up to 28 days but it's usually that
withdrawal is not as severe as other
kinds of withdrawals I know for me one
of the reasons I continued to drink
caffeine is because and I'm talking
about caffeine is because when I
withdraw from caffeine it's horrible so
I have to always have my coffee at least
once a day but cannabis use disorder I
think it's important for us to be able
to understand that we can develop this
if we don't pay attention but we can
develop maladaptive coping for many
different things not just cannabis as
well so how do we go forward from here
you know we really need to move towards
more of a personalized medicine approach
here pharmacogenomics is a really great
field I think this from my perspective
is vital to know how to my patients
actually metabolize cannabinoids and I
think we need to be able to move further
and looking at camp cannabis chemo bars
not just cannabis again like I said
earlier cannabis is a compound it's a
compound of different tama bars that
have different effects on the EECS and
mood regulation another issue is that we
have to we have to have standardized
products this is necessary not just for
research but for treatment and then they
need to be available to patients because
having a medicine available one week and
not available the next is is we should
not tolerate that it's inexcusable for
my from my point of view and that we
really need to look at treatment
formulations that should be based on
keema bark composition and we need to do
more research on healthy use of cannabis
healthy use can be defined as anything
that makes your life better and we don't
look at that cannabis can be used
positively for many things it can make
you feel more social it can make you
laugh more it can bond people it can
have so many different positive effects
that we have neglected to really kind of
look at the positive impact that
cannabis can use and for a consumer
that's really important when you do talk
to people who you know who use cannabis
they often say you know I just feel
better and it's such a shot as a subtle
shift you know it's for me
cannabis like I said earlier is that
gateway to wellness now I kind of want
to shift a little bit here at the end of
my talk because I want to talk about a
couple of cases because I think they
highlight how cannabis can be
effectively used but they also highlight
some of the major issues that we're
seeing in this field and that every
consumer needs to be aware of so we know
this is my case Michael he is a 52 year
old man
Caucasian male he has severe PTSD he
actually had identified found his wife
after she had committed suicide and had
been dead for many hours and it was an
incredibly traumatic event as you could
imagine
Michael had difficulties in sleep
flashbacks constantly intrusive thoughts
he also had feelings of isolation he was
very depressed and anxious all the time
and hyper vigilant hyper vigilant means
kind of like over reactive to things
so we know from animal models that
cannabis is vital for our can be helpful
for the treatment of PTSD we know that
mice who have been bred for example
without the receptors in their brain cb1
receptors that they had difficulty
actually forgetting and and moving
beyond harmful thoughts and memories
this is fascinating for me because this
is exactly what happens with PTSD when
you have those recurrent flashbacks
those memories of these things that
you've witnessed that are so troubling
that it actually debilitates a person's
functioning and for this example and
Michael he was feeling all of those
kinds of things but I know he has an
endocannabinoid system I know he has
these receptors in his brain and the
idea is is that if this works in a mouse
study ideally we should be able to
replicate this with human work so
Michael came to me very upset a couple
years after his wife had passed and was
seeking therapeutic help he couldn't
tolerate any antidepressant he tried a
couple of different antidepressants he
didn't like the way they made him feel
he felt detached from everything
generally healthy guy just really was
struggling with his PTSD following his
wife's suicide and we know that the ECS
is really linked to hyper vigilance and
negative emotionality so we know that a
dysregulated ECS actually would be
exacerbating hyper vigilance would be
demonstrating more negative emotions and
we know that the healthy ECS actually
allows of this extinction of aversive
memories remember what I said about the
mice being bred without the cb1
intercept
they were unable to forget that
traumatic stimuli and remember that the
EC SS job is to help eat sleep forget
and rest we need to forget certain
things and flashbacks is that inability
to forget that horrible trauma you've
experienced so Michael came to me he
couldn't tolerate the antidepressants he
was severely depressed as a clinician I
was highly concerned for him and he and
I were talking and he decided that he
wanted to try cannabis
well I encouraged him to go through the
states program you know he what he had a
medical qualifying condition PTSD that
would allow him to get accepted into the
program and he was very kind of
resistant about that so he started
getting cannabis from his neighbor's son
I would ask him what are you using he
couldn't tell me he was kind of all over
the map with how he was feeling but
finally you know after my strong
suggestion we got him through the
medical cannabis program in the state
where he lives and had him start to go
to dispensary and we found that during
the daytime high CBD flower so you know
that actually helped him
it motivated him he felt better he
started golfing with friends started to
interact more and at night he was using
a variety that actually helped him sleep
a lot better that he felt more rested
and the flashback started going away and
the flashbacks just not having those
intrusive thoughts constantly helped him
feel better
his depression started to lift now I'm
not saying he became healthy I'm not
saying that he's cured what I am saying
is that the symptoms that he was
experiencing actually
me to do therapy more with him it
reduced his symptom ology and he was
able to engage in life again here's the
kicker
they quit carrying the products a couple
of the products he was using so he had a
struggle of well what do I do I can't
get it he would go every week hoping
that they would have the product that
helped him sleep at night and he
couldn't get it so that lack of
regulated supply really negatively
started to impact him again he started
to have difficulties with sleep but once
he was using the cannabis again he was
able to sleep better so it demonstrates
that cannabis actually helped remove
some of his PTSD symptoms or reduce some
of his PTSD symptoms and that he started
to gain more acceptance and that's a
huge thing for PTSD he started to gain
more acceptance about where he was and
he's doing much better today in cannabis
has been a great therapeutic tool for
him and his recovery from PTSD the last
case I want to talk to you about is Kim
Kim has anorexia she is 50 I think she's
55 year old woman who had struggled with
anorexia since her early teens had been
hospitalized 21 times now anorexia
typically is not allowed on any u.s.
medical qualifying conditions list
however it often coincides with PTSD so
fortunately she was able to get in the
states program because she had PTSD as
well we know that cannabis hasn't
demonstrated positive relief from
wasting syndrome you know this is one of
the reasons why people going undergoing
chemotherapy are always you know
encouraged to utilize cannabis it helps
them eat it helps them gain weight
and I had the pleasure of meeting a
researcher in Israel this past fall who
had done the study on THC that actually
also demonstrated that THC positively
impacted weight gain for inter exit
patients so Kim started using cannabis
she went to a budtender this person gave
Kim advice and the issue was this was
the one I had mentioned earlier where
she actually was taking her klonopin
because the cannabis was making her too
anxious and so when she came to me and
we started talking about them like we
were overweight
let's look at the varieties that are
available because obviously you are
using something that's not helpful for
you and this is again where I think our
system is flawed here so we were able to
find a cannabis variety that helped her
and she didn't she got off of her benzos
which is a huge issue benzodiazepine
usage and and we're really hopeful that
we can have used cannabis and
replacement of benzos and she was able
to do that
and the irony is she gained weight now
this is a woman who's been hospitalized
21 times and having worked with people
with trauma and eating disorders and
personality disorders over the year I
can tell you this that even if my
patients gain weight they do not like
that they gain weight they're angry that
they gain weight they might gain weight
just to to get the physicians and
everyone off their back and to avoid
hospitalization but that does not mean
that they like themselves at that weight
or accept themselves at that way this
was what was fascinating to me though
Kim was okay she was like you know yeah
I'm getting away but I feel better
so here is a woman who had been
hospitalized so many times who had
struggled with his condition for almost
40 years for 30-something
and she was able to gain weight she was
even able to do some other transitions
in her life that she felt better about
she was engaging with her family whereas
she had not really been doing that for a
lot and and she got better and she's
been out of the hospital for a year she
hasn't been into the hospital and since
she started cannabis and these are the
kinds of issues that are so important so
the issue here was that you know as a
consumer Kim had no idea that she wasn't
supposed to be using a variety that
might exacerbate her anxiety or take her
klonopin in addition to it you know she
she didn't know about the drug drug
interaction she didn't know that you
know there were different varieties that
would actually affect her differently I
spent a lot of time talking to her about
the endocannabinoids system and it's
fascinating especially with anorexia
that's one of my areas of interests you
know and and she got better so as we get
into cannabis and its impact on mental
health we see some positive changes we
have to go beyond case studies though to
really look at how the components of
cannabis the chemo bars within cannabis
actually do impact mood and mood
regulation and like I said earlier we
know that that that that reason is
because of the endocannabinoid system so
I know I've shared with you lots of
information I know
it's I'm sure you probably have
questions send me your questions I'll be
happy to respond but I really think that
we have this opportunity to change the
way we think about cannabis with mental
health thank you so much for your time
and I hope you enjoyed this thank you so
much Janet that informative presentation
I'd also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible as a final reminder Jam will
follow up with any questions you
submitted the
email that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we'll see you next time
bye-bye goodbye